It started as an idea.
What if we made a Deadpool movie?
There's only a few of us back then,
and looking back,
we had no idea how big it would become.
So innocent.
And yet the momentum that had started,
it was not really what we had in mind.
No, that didn't help things.
It was more of a hell no.
To be honest.
I mean, we eventually stopped asking.
We have no idea how that happened.
But I promise you, I'm looking into it.
Well, what's the movie? Got greenlit.
I went on a massive coke bender.
So, 2016, this little hazy for me.
They tell me the movie did well, though.
Ten years into it,
phase
one has exceeded our wildest expectations.
You know, if you told me back
then that one movie would spawn
an expo chance of two movie universe,
I'd have said that you were crazy.
But here we are.
But actual actors,
a moderate special effects budget
and several low level X-Men.
None of the big ones, though.
We've got to save something for phase two.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie.
This'll be my new Deadpool 3 Video
Hugh Jackman talking more about Wolverine,
the plot of the movie.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
because there's a bunch of Deadpool stuff
coming up this year.
They're going to be working on the movie
for most of the year,
so we'll get teasers like this
for most of this year.
The way Marvel has been pitching
it is meant to be this big turning point
during Marvel Phase six.
It's one of the early Marvel Phase
six movies
now, just based on the way
they've shuffled the schedule.
And when they talk about Tipping Point,
they're talking mostly
about the incursions in the Time runs out
storyline from the Avengers comics,
where you basically lead into Secret Wars.
Avengers five is going to be King Dynasty,
and that's mostly the dynasty of Kings,
as we found out in The Man of the WASP
Post-Credits scene.
That's going to be a little bit different
in that it's
mostly going to be the dynasty of kings
as this Kang the Conqueror called them
during the Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantumania Post-Credits scene.
Like the Council of Kings,
he just called them the Dynasty of Kings
going after the Avengers
and any of the other characters
from the multiverse
that we've seen, like Clea, for example,
that have been able
to breach the multiverse,
been able to cross between universes.
So when they started teasing the idea
of incursions during Doctor Strange
Multiverse of Madness,
like Reed Richards of the Fantastic
Four from the A38 Universe,
the rest of the Illuminati
were getting mad
at Doctor Strange for causing incursions
along with Scarlet Witch.
An incursion occurs when the boundary
between two universes erodes
and they collide,
destroying one or both.
The tipping point
that they're talking about is Deadpool
basically doing a version of Deadpool
kills the Marvel Universe
and just going off the rails
with incursions, destroying
a bunch of timelines
like you would expect Deadpool to do.
Given that he's been messing with cable's
time travel device.
Just going to have a wee bit of fun here.
Go pick up Wolverine on the way and cause
a whole bunch of incursions, huh?
One day your old pal Wade is going to ask
you to get back in the saddle again.
And when he does say yes,
but that was the whole reason why
the dynasty of Kings Way,
the Council of Kings wanted to go
after the Avengers,
the other regular hero characters,
because they had started to do stuff
like this.
And Deadpool just takes it to the extreme.
So Hugh Jackman lately
was talking more about the plot,
and he started talking about the idea
that he'll be playing
multiple versions of Wolverine,
which is the whole idea
that they'll be visiting in destroying
arguably different timelines,
visit different events of the X-Men movies
at Fox, in the Deadpool movies.
So for example, in the Deadpool
two Post-Credits scene, you see Deadpool
going around with cable's time
travel device messing with timelines,
which is basically a set up
that they're using for Deadpool three.
That's how it begins.
Him jumping around timelines, going
and killing versions of himself
and messing with other timelines.
I think this is one of the ways
they go back and they continue
to make fun of X-Men Wolverine origins.
Don't scratch
just cleaning up the timelines.
Ryan Reynolds was asked about this
in a big live event that he did recently,
and he said that abomination is on Hugh
Jackman like he's the one to blame
for X-Men Wolverine origins.
I had nothing to do with that.
I just did what I was told.
Then cut to the Deadpool
two post-credits scene and he goes back
and he kills that
other version of himself,
which they're treating like a variant.
Basically.
Like you talk about the Loki series
because the TVA is minutes.
Mobius
They're supposed to be in Deadpool three.
Obviously,
they'd be interested in stopping Deadpool
because he's messing
with so many timelines.
Hopefully while they're busy messing
with all those timelines.
So get Mobius
that jetskis wanted for so long,
But this is how Hugh Jackman winds up
playing multiple versions of Wolverine.
They'll probably have
a couple funny versions
and they're like,
he talked about two versions,
but I think the idea is
there'll be multiple versions,
like more than just two.
They already kind of teased that idea
during the Logan movie,
even though that was meant to be later
in the timeline.
And they're not going to mess
with the events of that movie too much.
That was what they were talking about
in the first teaser for the movie
that they dropped where the like, we know
you have questions.
I had a lot of questions.
I'm sure you had a lot of questions,
but rest assured,
we're going to answer them right now.
Like, for example, how is Wolverine alive?
Yeah,
after Logan, Logan takes place in 2029.
Totally separate thing.
Logan died in Logan. Not touching that.
There's lots of confusion going on here.
We're going to be messing with timelines.
Don't worry.
We're not going to completely erase
the events of Logan
because it was a great movie.
But during that movie
you saw the younger Wolverine clone.
This would be the same thing this time.
Those be having a little bit more fun,
playing a little more comedic way.
But this is how you see
all the different versions of Wolverine
that you've wanted to see from the comics.
Like the version in the yellow costume
might wind up being a variant.
Like they'll give it to us
because so many people been asking
for, like, Please put them in the classic
yellow costume from the comics
before he completely retired
from the role.
Remember, Hugh Jackman is coming back
as Wolverine during Avengers
six Secret wars
because there's going to be a lot
of multiverse characters from the Fox
Marvel movies, from the Sony Marvel movies
like Andrew Garfield,
Tobey Maguire version of Spider-Man.
We should do this again, like
all hang out.
It's nice that for sure. Yeah,
that's a good idea.
I'll grab your number
at the end of the battle.
So it's an easy prediction to make that
we will eventually see him in a version
of that yellow costume,
as well as pulling off a bunch of the Fox
Marvel movie cameos with older actors
coming back to play their characters
again, like OG Fantastic Four actors,
more classic X-Men actors
coming back and several low level X-Men.
None of the big ones, though.
We've got to save something for phase two.
The movie is meant to be a direct
continuation of the events of Deadpool
two, where Deadpool ended the movie
taking cable's time travel device.
And they're just going to say
that he continued
messing with timelines in the Fox
Marvel universe until eventually
he tries to save a younger Wolverine
from dying.
Earlier in his timeline
before the events of the Logan movie.
But while Deadpool is jumping around
in his timelines, that's how they feature
a lot of the cameos
from the old Fox Marvel movies,
like they're supposed to have cameos
from the original Fantastic Four movies.
I don't know which characters
are supposed to come back right now.
There have been rumors about Chris Evans
coming back, as is Johnny Storm.
He said previously he would love to do
that.
It's only coming back as Captain America
that he's kind of reticent about.
And they'll be saying
that Deadpool is jumping around
in a timeline that just specific
to the Fox Marvel universe
with a bunch of subtle variations
in minor timelines within it.
So this how
they explained the original Deadpool here
and the newer Deadpool, the old man Logan
Wolverine,
are all from the same Fox Marvel universe,
but within that
they come from different timelines.
But that's why I've been making jokes
about Deadpool Kills the Fox
Marvel Universe
because Kevin Foggy
recasting a lot of the X-Men,
the Fantastic
Four characters inside the MCU.
So what better way to give the Fox
Marvel movies a big sendoff and honor them
and make fun of them a lot,
canonizing them through the multiverse
just like they did with Tobey
Maguire Spider-Man movies.
Andrew Garfield's Amazing Spider-Man
movies in Spider-Man, No Way Home,
and then proceed to do a version
of Deadpool Kills the Marvel Universe,
but just have him destroy or mess
with the Fox Marvel Universe.
I've done a couple of videos
about how Deadpool three
is going to be a huge crossover
with the Loki series because the TVA,
Mobius and Miss Minutes are going to be
big characters in the movie,
really hoping Deadpool helps Mobius
get that jetski.
They also just cast the main villain
in for Deadpool three,
and it's going to be Emma Corrin
from the Crown, who most of you remember
played a version of Diana Spencer.
They haven't said which character
she's playing, but given the tone
and the vibe of the character,
she is known for playing
the different types of characters
she's played.
It seems that the character she'll play
will be a little more subtle
as opposed to the tone and the vibe.
The way Ryan Reynolds performs.
Deadpool's is super over-the-top
character, and Hugh Jackman plays
Wolverine is is way more hardcore
type of character right now.
The leading theories for that villain
character are Typhoid Mary and Madcap,
who are big Deadpool villains,
but I don't think they're very likely.
We're talking about a big multiverse.
Time runs out, lead up to Avengers
five, Kang Dynasty kind of villain.
So the leading theories right now
are actually Lady Death,
which I think is more likely
given death's role in the other major
Marvel stories like the Thanos Infinity
Gantlet storyline.
They didn't really include the death
character during the Avengers,
Infinity War, Avengers Endgame movies.
Lady Death is also a huge figure
in Deadpool's past, she's the cosmic
entity death.
She can't really be killed the same way
you kill characters like Thanos.
She's the personification of all death
in the multiverse.
Like there's only one death
for the entire multiverse.
That's the introduction
of some of the cosmic entities
during Thor, Love and Thunder.
The death character was also featured
during that is one of the statues.
But you didn't actually see
a living version of death.
It was meant to be a representation
of death, not the actual death character,
but at least are trying to get into that
really weird, really high level stuff.
The other possibility,
and this is also a little more likely,
is that she's playing a Deadpool variant
and she's playing Lady Deadpool
from the comics who has been featured
a lot before, like in the Deadpool core.
She's from another universe.
Her name is Wanda Wilson,
and all her villains.
Her adventures are just meant to be twists
on the main version of Deadpool
and his history.
And when I mentioned the Deadpool core,
they could have jokes or references
about that at some point during the movie
because this is meant
to be a multiverse movie
and you have this idea
of a bunch of Deadpool variants
from across the multiverse
all forming a team together.
They're actually already using that idea
during Spider-Man across the Spider-Verse
with Spider-Man 2099, putting together
a multiverse team of Spider-Men.
So let me know in the comments.
Which Deadpool three villain
do you think Emma Corrin is going to play?
Big Reminder My Mandalorian Season
three Episode four Video A post this week.
Click here for that article link
as soon as I posted and click here for
that new Justice League Darkside returns
trailer that Zack Snyder just posted.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe and maximum effort.